[Musique]
pour examiner le malaise paysan en
bretagne monsieur michel debré est allé
à rennes le 24 janvier nous avons pris
la même route quelques jours plus tard
président du conseil a écouté les
doléances des cultivateurs le malaise
n'est pas sain nous avons essayé d'en
dessiner la silhouette en nous rappelant
ce que nous avions entendu de plus
significatifs au cours d'une dizaine de
conversations premières questions
auxquelles les autres s'enchaînent
lorsque les paysans du morbihan pensent
à leur travail à la situation qui leur
est faite
quel sentiment éprouvez t-il monsieur le
maire de plérin m'a répondu aux beaucoup
de découragement principalement chez les
jeunes ne sont pas les vieux qu'ils y
sont ils y restent mais après cela ça va
de pire en pire
et d'où vient ce découragement parce
qu'il n'ya pas de rénumération vis-à-vis
des travaux et des des produits que l'on
vend vous avez calculé le la valeur de
votre heure de travail
oui j'ai fait un petit calcul l'année
dernière sur la ferme que mes parents
exploiter j'ai trouvé que sur l'ensemble
de notre venue
on a gagné environ par personne à raison
de 12 heures par jour
on a gagné environ 22 francs par heure
environ
autre composante des malaises de les
transports sont beaucoup trop élevés
on voudrait acheter la paille de
fourrage admettant que des venant de la
beauce et bien que le transport coûte à
peu près le double de ce que vaut la
marchandise la question principale
les prix agricoles qui ne sont plus
indexés ne suffisent plus les prix
industriels
depuis plusieurs années il ya déjà un
décalage qui s'accentue mais notamment
l'année dernière dans la campagne 58 59
les prix agricoles ont baissé d'environ
10% alors que les produits industriels
en tourmentés d'environ 10% ce qui fait
un décalage de 20% en 40 et quelques un
petit tracteur de ferme vous l'aviez
pour 80 milles le cheval valait 80
milles et maintenant on n'a qu'à mettre
un cheval auprès d'un facteur quel prix
que ça revient à peu près huit fois plus
haut facilement facilement vous trouvez
aussi qu'il ya trop d'intermédiaires
oui je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup trop
d'intermédiaires par exemple je vois le
chou-fleur il est vendu sur pieds
environ sens où est arrivé à paris là et
face au sein de différents c'est quand
même beaucoup d'intermédiaires alors que
c'est nous autres qui avons du travail
1,9 qui est vendu à plumelec 12 ou 13
pour cent cinquante ans la douzaine
aujourd'hui et qui allait sur le marché
de paris à 33 fin comment voyez-vous
l'avenir par ici on va à l'avenir par
ici je vois que ça va aller de pire en
pire pour la campagne save wade les est
de plus en plus tout le monde va partir
on va tout le monde doit partir oui vous
avez un fils qui est resté à bas il est
resté oui mais pas très enchanté pour le
moment pour regretter de ne pas avoir
pris comme votre frère à une autre voie
certainement j'ai eu là bas non frères
étaient fuzeré pas seulement moi mais ma
femme quand vous le voyez vous voyez
comme une vie il donne envie
voici le frère qui donne envie il a
quitté la ferme depuis neuf ans quel est
votre profession monsieur que j'ai signé
à bord de l'oranie tout un cadeau et
dernier voyage et beaucoup n'ont fait la
france l'algérie
vous êtes content content très content
regretté de pas avoir de vacances tout
naturellement donc à la banque de
loisirs ni aucun loisir chez nous c'est
pas connu la campagne c'est l'esclave
voilà grossièrement résumé le malaise
paysan il est à la fois économiques et
psychologiques main donc pour que vous
puissiez en évaluer le sérieux nous
avons voulu vous montrer comment vivent
ceux qui l'éprouvent nous avons choisi
la commune de plumelec proche de vannes
la commune de plumelec a beaucoup changé
en dix ans madame dubois est maintenant
la seule à ne pas avoir l'électricité
les chemins sont plus creux toutes les
fermes sont reliées entre elles par des
routes véritable les parcelles de terre
ont été regroupées
l'état lui qui les isoler les unes des
autres ont été arasées
la commune de plumelec est aujourd'hui
entièrement remembrer grâce à son maire
monsieur brunel
[Musique]
monsieur le maire vous êtes l'homme du
remembrement avant ce remembrement votre
commune était divisé en combien de
parcelles environ 27000 environ est
maintenant un peu plus 3000 3200 vous
avez à raser un grand nombre de km de
talus
nous avons à raser environ 530 km de
talent et ce qui a donné une josiane
nous a permis de récupérer quelques 400
hectares de terres cultivables
vous avez fait de nouveaux chemins de
nouvelles routes nous avons construit 50
km de chemins ruraux
je sois lui au couteau nécessairement
tous les villages et où les fermes et
nous avons construit l'année dernière
vous les 20 km de chemins d'exploitation
comme une pilote plumelec paraît donc en
bonne situation et bien pourtant à
plumelec une ferme sur cinq seulement
permet à son propriétaire ou à son
fermier de vivre correctement et une
ferme sur deux n'est pas viable assurant
seulement la subsistance
entre ces deux extrêmes il y a les
fermes d'une quinzaine d'hectares où
l'envi vote
nous avons voulu vous montrer comment
vivent ces trois classes de paysans
premier exemple la ferme de monsieur
noël etienne qui est moyenne un peu
moins de 20 hectares on sait vous
monsieur etienne que les gens des villes
croire vraiment aux difficultés des
paysans
je ne pense pas d'importance aux villes
j'ai l'impression que dans les villes on
pense assez souvent que les paysans
gagne finalement pas mal d'argent
oui mais c'est une erreur une erreur
profonde parce que sur loin de gagner de
l'argent et paysans
j'ai l'impression que d'après tout ce
que vous avez dit que vous ne pouvez
vous en tirer que parce que vous avez
une vie très très austère oui
certainement
vous avez très peu de loisirs ne rendra
pas à quelle heure on pourrait
d'ailleurs prendre parce que faute de
temps faute de temps et puis les paysans
ne sont pas justement assez
non certainement pas assez d'argent
justement pour pouvoir par des loisirs
vous êtes à combien de kilomètres de la
mer ici nous sommes à 300 400 km vous y
allez quelquefois ou jamais d'aller au
cinéma quelquefois non plus c'est
d'aller à paris je n'y suis jamais allé
j'y suis passé mais vous ne sortez d'ici
que lorsque vous avez une affaire
précise affaire jamais pour votre
plaisir ne jamais toujours ce soit pour
affaire de commerce ou alors parfois
quelques mariages ou enterrements pour
vous distraire vous ne dépensez rien pas
de femme et sa suite à la télévision un
de ces jours où je ne pense pas pour
tout de suite toujours où il faudrait
que les temps soient meilleurs pouvoir
payer la télévision vous ferez mettre
l'eau courante avant la chute et la
télévision ont certainement beaucoup
plus nécessaire c'est surtout votre
fille que ça doit priver ah oui
certainement et obligé de laver au
lavoir
oui ça n'est pas trop dur madame de
l'abbé dehors comme ça partout le temps
mais pas très envie d'avoir l'eau
courante mais aussi certainement à côté
de vos obligations de mère de famille
qui travaille faites vous à la ferme
jacques soigner les bêtes lui
la vache a raconté bonne journée de
travail n'importe laquelle
le battage seul élevage après je sonne
les cochons et les hommes sauvages
le restylage fait le ménage la cuisine
jusqu'à l'oubli alors l'après midi je
dois m'en ce jeu là d'un petit peu c'est
à dire que j'ai
alors je la veux plus que l'après midi
et puis je préfère tourner
l'espoir alors quand les hommes je sais
de l'école choix que quand les invendus
chants en estonie vaches encore moi je
préfère le bruit on l'espère vous lever
à quelle heure vous touchez à quelle
heure on se lève à 5h le matin et on se
couche
vous êtes pensez vous que ce soit l'un
travaille très dur trop dur pour une
femme passe et boules parce que ça
n'allait jamais les bateaux à ce manque
pas non
pas de vacances le sortie les loisirs le
cinéma tout ça continue
musquin pas tellement ça c'est en avait
seulement plus commodités pour le savait
et on chercherait pas mieux
quoi
je viens de voir votre mari est votre
père du selon que vous êtes mariés
depuis deux heures de spa
avant de vous marier
je souhaite poser la question de savoir
si vous aviez envie de rester à la ferme
ou bien d'aller pareilles ans
jamais cherché à fuir mais jamais
cherché à martin avant de quitter les
etienne j'ai posé une question au mari
il y a eu une grande manifestation de
paysans du morbihan au mois de décembre
en espagne il ya six mois à peine
c'était une manifestation calme oui très
calme mais pas barrer les routes
non on ne peut pas on n'a pas le
matériel pour le baril pas de voiture ni
tracteur voici au complet le cheptel de
madame veuve boulvé attention la moitié
des exploitants de plumelec possède une
ferme comparable à celle ci où l'on peut
juste subsister
[Musique]
combien d'hectares avez vous mal à me
lever et sur scène avec ta combien sont
cultivables
qu'est ce que vous faites là dessus de
légumes oui quoi par exemple les choux
pommes de terre et les traîtres pour
vous abonner rôle on vous en demande et
aussi combien avez vous de vache
3 faites à votre beurre oui vous êtes
force de guerre monoï oui mais si vous
n'aviez pas votre pension est ce que
vous pourriez vivre tout juste vous êtes
seul qui vous aide
votre beau frère jean frère de temps en
temps j'ai besoin
pensez vous que votre fille devrait
prendre votre suite devrait être
exploité cette ferme
pourquoi c'est un peu trop petit ça
tombe bien d'ailleurs je crois ne
voulait pas assez la campagne ne voulait
plus vivre la campagne
et si vous épouse y est un multi batteur
non non je veux pas non ça sont remis à
zéro mais votre fiche ou millions vous
savez 50 hectares l ademe en battant pin
et pourquoi ne voulez-vous puis vers la
campagne expliquez moi pourquoi
voulez-vous quitter la terre ça
m'intéresse pas qu'est ce qui vous
intéresse
c'est toujours ça je sais pas danser je
crois à danser oui vous avez
l'impression qu'on danse plus souvent en
ville qu'en campagne
oui j'en serais beaucoup litres en ville
vous aimez danser vous madame vous levez
pareil
comment imaginez vous la vie que vous
avez envie d'avoir dit vous voulez aller
travailler à paris
non pourquoi
c'est trop loin ces trois mois oui
qu'est ce que voulait faire
avaya van van bon alors une fois van
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de faire
j'avais envie d'habiter ou par exemple
l'appartement ou qu'est ce qu'il y
aurait dans ses appartements
vous riez un peu vous avez pensé à ça
non plus modernes du moderne on voit que
c'est dans les gènes
qu'est ce qui vous plaît le plus dans
l'idée de vivre en ville travailler en
rien en dehors dedans c'est les vacances
n'a jamais pris de vacances j'ai très
envie
vous ne regrettez pas ce qu'on
regretterait pas ce feu de cheminée
n'ont sûrement si ce poulailler
appartenait à madame soulever sa fille
n'aurait sans doute pas une si exclusive
envie de partir mais ces poulets sont la
propriété de monsieur tard que nous
avons choisie pour représenter les
exploitants de plumelec possédant une
ferme de plus de 20 hectares
[Musique]
la vie ici est moins aride mais
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a seulement un
exploitant sur cinq à plumelec dans la
situation comparable à celle de monsieur
tatar électricité ici est familière
combien d'hectares exploiter vous me
jette à terre pleins de ses lecteurs
vous êtes content de votre production
oui ça marche bien à peu près qu'est ce
que vous faites et blé cultivé blé un
peu d'avoir les neufs
c'est aussi un peu tout l'élevage et
jamais je suis noir des poules et
poulets oui très cher beaucoup de poulet
douzaine de milles année nous en 2001
l'année
c'est votre femme qui s'en occupe oui
qui travaillent avec vous dehors de
votre femme
j'ai deux fils qui travaille avec man
une fille la fille comment voyez vous
votre avenir mademoiselle j'espère
rester cultivatrice souhaitez vous
épousez un cultivateur vivre en ville ne
vous tente pas du tout vous préférez le
travail de la campagne au travail la
ville oui pourquoi est-ce qu'on a une
vie plus libre plus libre on passe club
des heurts ni du travail comme dans les
usines par les vacances ne vous tente
pas par exemple si et vous vous y
renoncer oui vous aimez danser
oui beaucoup voulons c'est souvent dans
seriez plus en ville oui mais tant pis
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de
cultivateurs des environs n'arrivent pas
à joindre les deux bouts qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais pas de commerce vous
avez vous l'impression qu'ils sont aussi
bons cultivateurs que vous peut-être pas
tout difficile à dire oui
vous vous êtes bon cultivateurs comment
êtes vous devenu en travaillant
l'étudiante étudiants comment l'alcool
vous avez lu vos fils pendant votre
suite ainsi les enfants de monsieur
tatar n'iront pas travailler au
préventorium de plumelec couvrons
s'embaucher beaucoup de ceux et de
celles qui ne veulent pas reprendre la
ferme de leurs parents mais la plupart
des jeunes gens moins chanceux partent
aussi monsieur le maire est il inquiet
ce que nous voudrions c'est que il reste
tout de même à la campagne des jeunes
gens et des jeunes filles intelligent
parce que je nous nous croyons nous
sincèrement qu'il est peut-être plus
difficile aujourd'hui de faire un bon
cultivateurs que faire un ouvrier
d'usiné par exemple ou un malheur
monsieur brunel fait tout à plumelec
pour qu'on ait envie d'y rester
[Musique]